- I heard the girl that
played the 13-year-old you,
Christa Allen, is turning 30 this year,
if that doesn't make us all feel old.
She did a few TikTok tributes.
Here is one, I gotta show you.
- You know what?
You are rude and mean
and sloppy and frizzy.
I don't like you at all.
(crowd laughs)
- (laughs) Love that she did that.
Have you seen them?
- She is uncanny.
Yes, I've seen her.
She played the young
me in "13 Going On 30,"
and then again in "Ghost
of Girlfriends Past"
because I needed a
young me again and said,
"I know the perfect young lady."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so, you know, I've
always been aware of her
since then, and we've kind of
texted or DMed back and forth,
and whenever I see her, she's
just like a prettier version
of me at 30.
Look at her, it's crazy.
(Kelly laughs)
- How did she have that dress?
I don't have that dress.